I just got an email letting me know
that Sarah commented on my pull request.
She says that I misspelled canola.
Well, I'll go take a look.
Canols oil.
Yeah that's not right.
I'll go ahead and fix that.
And I'll commit my fix.
Now since I want this change to be
visible on GitHub also I'll push.
Pushing the branch automatically
updates the pull request on GitHub.
Underneath Sarah's comment about
my misspelling you can see my
commit fixing the typo.
Also, if I look at the commits
I can see there are two now.
And if I look at the files changed
I can see the correct spelling.
Now I'd like you to
follow the same steps and
make a pull request on your own.
First, create a new branch
called different-oil,
then make a different commit
on the different-oil branch,
to use canola oil instead of
vegetable oil like I did.
If you want, you can make a typo
on purpose but that's optional.
Then push your different-oil
branch to your fork on GitHub and
create a pull request.
Make sure to change the base to
the master branch of your repository and
not Larry's repository.
If you made a typo earlier, then make
another commit to fix the typo and
update the pull request.
Finally, paste the link to
your pull request in this box.
You can find a link to your pull request
by viewing your repository on GitHub,
scrolling over to the right, and
looking at the list of pull requests.
Then click on your pull requests,
and copy this URL from the URL bar.
Finally, make sure you don't
merge the pull request yet.
If you do,
then a later exercise won't work